pedro tiene que practicar piano tres
cuartos de hora diariamente tres cuartos
de hora diariamente ok si el día de hoy
lleva un cuarto de hora solamente lleva
un cuarto de hora entonces cuál es la
fracción de horas que le falta por
practicar ok pues qué te parece si para
empezar a resolver este problema nos
vemos de una manera visual así que
imagínate que esta es una hora tengo
aquí una hora ok y entonces déjame poner
que este es el principio de la hora este
es el final de la hora y vamos a
dividirlo a la mitad
vamos a dividir a la mitad si aquí
empieza a la hora ok vamos a ponerlo más
grande aquí es el final de la hora aquí
es la mitad y ahora permitimos la mitad
en mitades por lo tanto tengo cuartas
partes esta es una hora entera y de una
hora entera pedro tiene que practicar el
piano tres cuartos de hora
así que tiene que practicar el piano
hasta que vamos a ponerlo tiene que
practicar el piano de aquí o key
perfecto todo este tiempo es lo que
tiene que practicar diariamente pedro de
piano muy bien ahora si nosotros sabemos
que pedro tiene que practicar tres
cuartos de hora diariamente de piano
pero el día de hoy lleva solamente un
cuarto de hora cuánto le falta pedro por
déjame colorearlo bien cuando hace falta
pedro para completar estos tres cuartos
que por cierto vamos a escribirlo aquí
son tres cuartos de hora lo que tiene
que hacer diariamente y en esta ocasión
pedro solamente lleva un pato de aquí
hasta acá esto ha sido lo que ha
practicado pedro el día de hoy esto es
lo que ha practicado pedro
ok si esto lo que ha practicado pedro el
día de hoy que por cierto solamente es
un cuarto de hora cuánto le falta para
alcanzar lo que practica diariamente
bueno pues de una manera muy visual tú
me puedes decir que es de aquí te falta
de aquí hasta acá para que termine su
práctica diaria de piano le falta todo
esto de practicar a pedro para llegar a
lo que practicar diariamente de piano
todo esto es lo que le falta a pedro
ahora bien tal vez de una manera muy
rápida tú lo puedas decir el resultado
sí ya lo estamos viendo de una manera
gráfica pero como lo podemos expresar
este mismo problema cómo podemos
encontrar esta flecha de color salmón de
una manera matemática
bueno pues de una manera matemática
podemos decir que al día pedro tiene que
practicar tres cuartas partes de ahora
el instrumento de piano ya esto le voy a
quitar lo que ya lleva
practicado pedro el día de hoy lo que ya
he practicado pedro el día de hoy ha
sido un cuarto de hora y lo padre es que
aquí tenemos una diferencia de
fracciones que tienen un denominador
común el denominador común es 4 y por lo
tanto cuando tengo esta diferencia de
fracciones me voy a tomar 3 -1 esto ya
lo sabemos por el vídeo de suma y resta
de fracciones y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que como tenemos un denominador
común 2 entre 4 2 entre 4 es decir que
nos faltan 2 cuartos de hora esto es dos
cuartos de hora lo que nos falta para
terminar de practicar el piano por el
día de hoy ahora seguramente tú me estás
diciendo que dos cuartos se puede
simplificar y lo podemos ver de la
siguiente manera si yo tengo por ejemplo
aquí un cuadrado y este cuadrado lo
divido en cuatro partes lo voy a dividir
en cuatro partes ok
dividido en cuatro partes yo me tomo dos
cuartas partes me tomaría esta parte de
aquí y esta parte de acá y seguramente
en ese momento me estás diciendo que
esto es lo mismo que tomarme la mitad
del cuadrado
si me toma un cuadrado igual un cuadrado
igual algo más o menos así ya está
cuadrado ahora lo divido en dos partes
ok vamos a dividirlo en dos partes si te
das cuenta en la parte de arriba es la
que está coloreada esta parte de aquí es
la que está coloreada entonces me vas a
decir que dos cuartos es exactamente lo
mismo que la mitad o que un medio del
cuadrado y como no podemos ser
matemáticamente hablando bueno pues que
te parece es vivido entre dos tanto el
numerador como el denominador de esta
fracción voy a dividir entre 2 esta
parte entre 2 esta parte y entre 2 esta
parte y me atrevo a hacer eso porque
tanto el 2 como el 4 son divisibles
entre 2 y estoy haciendo lo mismo tanto
arriba como abajo y cuánto me quedaría
de esto
pues 2 entre 2 me va a dar 1 y 4 entre
29 dardos por lo tanto dos cuartos es lo
mismo que un medio le falta a pedro un
medio de hora o media hora para
finalizar su práctica diaria de piano
hasta la próxima